remember back when the ballarant pro
scene first started cs go talent was
pouring in and every esports org was
scrambling to put the world's best
aimers in front of a monitor
does he have it in them does that gene
work here in berlin you've got the two
members of liberty creeping their work
forward he goes good for one the 1v1
he's going to get info
taps out there he hasn't even gotten it
to happen
baby spencer martin does it again a red
bull clutch for 100 thieves well here we
stand at the very beginning of the
second year of the devour and champions
tour and everything has changed
teams aren't just looking to fill their
rosters with the best available cs go
talent this game has its own positions
its own roles and the teams that are
filling their rosters accordingly
are turning into household names
overnight
let me explain
[Music]
as long as i'm up here and i can still
talk like kermit the frog in front of a
camera
we're keeping the ballering content
coming so if you're a val head and you
like heady analysis videos like this one
make sure you scroll down subscribe to
the channel like the video and leave me
a comment okay so the texture and makeup
of the professional valerian team has
been fast moving and exciting to watch
and we've finally gotten to the point
where teams aren't just going out and
finding the best available
counter-strike talent to fill their
rosters they're going out and they're
getting position-specific
home-grown valorant demons players like
cryo cells on xset xander on v1 and even
baby j on the new look 100 thieves
roster and to better understand how we
got to this point let's go back to the
beginning at the beginning of december
2020 when hundred thieves became the
champions of first right on the backs of
og north american stalwarts like hiko
nitro and steel at the time north
american bauer was filled with
well
a lot of nacs goes rejects the nacs
scene was floundering it was really hard
to keep rosters together and a lot of
mid-tier talent was flocking towards
valerian for a new opportunity we're
talking names like sick tens shazam
dapper wardell sabrosa brax skadoodle
vanity and yay okay the cosmic divide is
actually what's gonna play contact you
see the smoke come out and the gravity
well bcj was a sitting duck he gets
cleaned up by yay and yeah gets the
second one as well 34 health
dancing around the corner he gets three
and diablo baby you gotta fear him look
it for four this is why you fear this
man this is why he's so highly touted
because he makes plays like that happen
now these might sound like household any
valorant names to you right now but back
then we watched with uncertain eyes as
they had to prove themselves all over
again it's not like we were watching
rosters filled with asunas who
may have came from cs but was 16 when he
started playing val the guy's like not
even his prime yet no mostly we were
watching esports veterans try to
reinvent their career by learning a
completely new game and that meant
learning some of the games newfound
positions and after an entire year three
masters events and lcq and valor and
champs we have exactly that
five solidified positions or roles that
make up a valor and roster
with
some room for interpretation first of
course
we've got the jet main or
primary duelist
when jet gets inevitably nerfed in all
seriousness one of my biggest takeaways
from champions was how important it was
to have an op wielding high-flying jet
player at the top of your scoreboard a
lot of the games we watched had the
likes of yay c ned durka and tens
jockeying for position and taking long
range fights against one another and at
least for now it seems like if you want
to be a top team you got a jet good next
we've got controllers or smokes this
one's pretty straightforward smokes are
and always will be an integral part of
the game and its team compositions and
especially how the game works now where
astra is completely broken and viper is
a necessity on specific maps
you gotta have a smoker then we got the
sentinel yes somebody has to be able to
expertly play off their kj bot and
what's more is with the addition of
chamber to a lot of competitive lineups
this position is looking like a key
secondary opera role for a lot of top
teams i for one am looking forward to
seeing cloud nine's mitch with the
chamber up in his hands this year i'm
gonna johnny i'm gonna join here one
u-haul pushing up you-ho
shower trooper
all right
on jet one's like right on the other
side oh cue whole area that's on u-haul
hit 40.
let's go
one thing of note here is that we often
see players who aren't traditional
sentinel players like cipher and killjoy
flex onto sage when their teams play on
icebox sikh comes to mind as someone who
normally plays flashes but hops onto
sage when necessary as the pro meta has
developed ko and sky have become huge
parts of team compositions across most
maps they offer an honestly pretty
insane amount of diversity in gameplay
and utility they can obtain info they
can entry and they can support your team
if you need it and as last year went on
we saw players like zeke ethan sabroza
sick shine on what are some of the most
difficult agents to play in the game and
before you jump down my throat i know
that some of these players are good
enough that they can flex onto other
roles like rey's sova and viper when
their team needs it last but not least
we've got the initiator or well
soba means silva remains one of the most
important most difficult and frankly
most essential characters in competitive
games which in retrospect makes what
shazam did flexing onto sova off of jet
for tens all the more impressive even if
that means flexing on maps like split
and fracture where he doesn't shine as
much and these five rules have brought
us to the north american art world we
have sitting in front of us right now
literally as this video is being
published cloud9 is playing a revamped
version of that same hundred thieves
team that won first strike way back in
december 2020 rebuilt with much of what
i'm discussing right now in mind teams
like except who needed a jet player this
offseason to round out their roster so
they brought in the best one on the
market my boy cryo cells finally takes
one of the side of the head the office
here the knives are on and
looks to steal it back he goes up he
cuts down jerk and now calypso
the last one standing here the op comes
out the angle of hell then cryo clutch
on freakingrealcryo1v3
to pull it off at the very end and cryo
and company have been on a roll
cementing their spot in the challenger's
main event and winning the nerd street
gamers winter championship
where cryo was plus 22 in their final
sweep the same could be said about
version one who were reeling just a
little bit after their loss of vanity to
cloud9 last year but they went out and
signed zander to fill their smoke slot
who has looked nasty in the early going
but he needs to hurry up because the
crew's starting to catch frags pits down
1v2
standard oh gets the head shot of the
transfer
unbelievable and a well found clutch
version one needed that 100 thieves same
thing instead of going out and signing
some random nacs go player they got baby
j to fill their needs for a high quality
sentinels player and echoes from eu to
fill their need for a smokes player
and speaking of eu the same thing can be
said about fnatic they signed brave f as
a dedicated sova player this offseason
which will allow boaster to focus on
smokes and allow durka to play duelist
on every map whereas previously he had
to play soba on behind
and don't even get me started on the
guard who went out this offseason and
built a completely new roster based
around these five positions and have
looked absolutely nasty so far with saya
playa on the jet and trent on the sofa
and the igl to support cryo drops down
so does aaron they aren't actually the
one to fall
death does him part and now the shock
darts bcj trying to play legolas and
shrek stays alive now look at the hb
it's a 1v2 and it's doable he spots out
one wallbang where is it it's a
possibility trying to line it up trent
he finds it and now it's a one versus
one
unaware of the position of the other
last known in close to single bullet to
reveal the whooping it is trent
as far as i can tell this
is the new reality teams have figured
out how they want their rosters to look
while they're preparing for all those
different meta compositions on each map
they're not looking for raw aim they're
looking for homegrown valor and talent
that is adept at these specific skill
sets and that new reality seems to be
shining the brightest on the teams that
put the most work in this offseason
and that's got me very excited to watch
100 thieves play okay so let's tie this
narrative up a little bit the fact of
the matter is
restrictive positions and roles have had
a pretty tenuous history in the world of
esports in league of legends for example
the game is basically balanced around
the five roles but fans often wax
nostalgic missing a time when the roles
weren't so restricted in overwatch
blizzard hoped that a dedicated role cue
would stop the pervasiveness of tanks
and supports at the highest level but
the pros ended up hating the
restrictiveness and the lack of creative
expression that the system offered and
for me valorent has a chance to be the
best of both worlds where teams are
designed and balanced around these
unique roles but you've got guys like
shazam who plays sova and jet zeppa who
plays ko and reyes and sick who can
seemingly play any position and any
agent
showing us just how well-rounded you can
be at this game right now the game is
really towing a fine line and has a
chance to surpass many esports in the
way that its roles play out for me it's
truly the esports pro's magical
christmas land
so
let's keep it that way
well i think i'm i'm i'm thoroughly
turned into toxic jet moon
i only i only ever want to play jet i
only ever install jet and
there's something about playing jet you
know like it's like you lock in that jet
she spins the knife on her hand and
you're like you got a little adrenaline
boost and you're like oh yeah
today's my day